[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren viertel nach acht den nächsten 15
minuten sprechen über corona russland
und neuenburg waren sind an der uni sie
dass eine sendung passt ja das erklärt
den besonderen zauber von viertel nach
acht heute abend zu gast ich freue mich
sehr der bundestagsabgeordnete und
vorsitzende cdu hamburg der gerade die
schlagzeilen dominiert dazu aber später
mehr neben mir bild redakteur kai viktor
wachse in cambridge studiert hat und dem
zu jeder bild schlagzeile ein
shakespeare zitat einfällt vielleicht
frage ich das später auch noch mal ab an
meiner seite bild politik chef jan
schäfer niemand erklärt politik wie er
versprechen dass wir euch einiges lernen
werden last but not least der
außerplanmäßigen professor der
universität münster professor volk holen
es laborleiter des medizinischen labors
münsters und vertritt in der kroner
pandemie eine ganz andere meinung sie
dürfen gespannt sein mein name ist lena
steht und ich freue mich die runde heute
eröffnen zu dürfen mein thema ist heute
abend der deutsche freedom day ist eine
farce was ich damit meine während andere
eu länder öffnen kriechen wir noch fünf
wochen der freiheit entgegen pünktlich
zum morgigen corona gipfel mit den
länderchefs hat das kanzleramt einen
ersten fahrplan für das ende der korona
maßnahmen vorgelegt ab vierten märz
sollen restaurants hotels die
dreijährige gelten klingt erst mal gut
am 20 märz soll dann der freedom day
sein es sollen alle tiefgreifenden
schutz maßnahmen fallen aber die maske
soll weiterhin in innenräumen bussen und
bahnen getragen werden was ist das für
ein studium day für die kinder ist es
noch schlimmer eine welt recherche ergab
dass außer schleswig holstein bislang
nur rheinland-pfalz und sachsen-anhalt
ein mögliches ende der masken für kinder
schüler platz auf welcher grundlage
sollen die kinder noch länger dieser
unsäglichen maske in der schule sitzen
die massen fließen muss endlich fallen
und das für alle und wir müssen meiner
meinung nach sofort öffnen ich hoffe
dass die deutsche politik sich besinnt
und wir beim fühlen weg nicht wieder den
deutschen kroner sonderweg in ja da gehe
ich ihnen völlig recht frau schenkt das
ist auch so man sieht dass in anderen
ländern es ist ja nicht ein anderes
virus was wir hier haben es anderen denn
das ist nicht hier ansteckender das sind
jetzt in der zeit von omikron das ist
eine variante die doch deutlich weniger
schwer wiegendes als sie als die
bisherigen und da gibt es keinen
rationalen grund zu zögern und das nicht
dass nicht sie sich dieses schrittweise
vorgehensweise hatte eigentlich keine
rationale begründung auch aus meiner
sicht ja
jetzt haben wir bei den film der ja was
ist ja so ein erst mal auf dem weg dahin
eigentlich ein ja bummel weg den wir
einschlagen schnecken weg und ich glaube
den punkt du auch gemacht hast mit den
masken und der masken pflicht für kinder
ich hatte das vergnügen auch einmal
zweieinhalb stunden die ganze zeit die
maske tragen zu dürfen hat festgestellt
das ist total nervig das ist total
anstrengend wenn wir uns anschauen wie
gering auf der einen seite die
ansteckungsraten ist das eine aber vor
allem auch folgewirkungen bei kinder
sind oder www knüpft die eigentlich mit
einer infektion umgehen und wie wir dann
aber zugleich auch sehen was es für
folgen
neben corona gibt beispielsweise den
dramatischen anstieg von suizidversuchen
im zweiten lockdown beispielsweise bei
kindern dann glaube ich ist der
allerhöchste eisenbahn geboten dann ist
auch die forderung zu sagen die maske
muss weg absolut legitim was wir den
kindern hier in dieser dieser pandemie
an zugemutet haben als wir den
schulkindern zugemutet haben das geht
eigentlich auf keine kuhhaut
ich wollte noch einen moderatoren
erlaubt
explizit aber trotzdem noch einmal
nachfragen denn du hast ja kinder und
ich glaube dass wir noch einmal tristan
zu hören wie du das erlebt hast an denen
diese tage diese jahre also das ist ganz
unterschiedlich aber das was ich erleben
konnte gerade wenn es um
diese wochen und diese monate ging
während zwei von den dreien die
schulpflichtig sind zu hause dann vom
computer sitzen mussten und das war mit
allen möglichen technischen problemen
die man sich auch vorstellen kann die
gab es auch nicht nur bei uns zu hause
habe dann auch bei der lehrerin bei an
schulkameraden also da unterricht zu
machen ist eine totale herausforderung
da etwas zu lernen eine umso größere und
dabei noch lustig fröhlich und den
glauben an das gute im leben auch nicht
zu verlieren eine absolute
herausforderung und das ist glaube ich
die größte zumutung die wir den kindern
machen konnten dass wir sie da haben
über monate allein ich sag jetzt mal
alleine natürlich mit eltern betreuung
aber alleine vor computern haben sitzen
lassen
ohne dass es irgendwas nebenbei gab und
dass sie jetzt in den klassen sitzen mit
maske und getan wird als wenn die welt
untergeht wenn sie diese maske abnehmen
würden das ist der eigentliche skandal
ein zusätzlich kann man ins stadion und
die entschuldigung das wollte ich immer
lust wenn man kann das stadion und die
kinder sehen dass und müssen arbeiten
unterricht diese maske auf haben und
dann müssen sie zu denken was ist im
steigen sind ja gerade auch wieder
limitiert aber ich glaube wenn man zb
eine vip karte hat dann klappt es dann
doch noch
also ich finde erst mal völlig richtig
dass wir endlich dahin kommen dass die
korona maßnahmen aufgehoben werden in
der jetzigen form und das muss auch
deutlich schneller gehen wir sehen ja in
nachbarland dänemark dass da schon die
menschen feiern in diskotheken an den
schulen ist es normal das leben hat sich
weitgehend normalisiert wie vor corona
und man sieht dass die sehr gut damit
umgehen können und sie haben es eben
völlig zu recht gesagt das ist ja da
nicht ein anderes virus als paar
kilometer weiter in deutschland deswegen
völlig richtig will aber einen
kritischen punkt jedoch anmerken ich
hatte gestern ein wunderbares instagram
live auf einem kanal mit dem henrik
strikt dem virologen den ich sehr
schätze weil er auch von beginn an immer
wieder nicht nur den virologischen blick
hatte aber nur dem virologischen blick
hat dann kann man ja sagen alle bleiben
am besten nur zu hause dann verbreitet
sich das virus nicht so auch im
gesamtgesellschaftlichen also welche
kollateralschäden gibt es was bedeutet
das für kinder und jugendliche was
bedeutet das fürs sozialleben und der
henrik hatte gestern gesagt erhält die
massen pflicht für sehr sinnvoll weil
die wirklich dazu führt dass sich das
virus nicht stark verbreitet dass er
einen sehr sehr hohen effekt und die
einschränkungen sind ja vergleichsweise
milde und dafür können wenn man in
vielen anderen bereichen öffnen und
lockern und ich kenne
aber die eigene die massen fliesst
offenbar so einfach umzusetzen dass in
der bundesversammlung die wir nun am
sonntag erlebt haben ist eine
40-minütige masken pause gab die fdp hat
die fdp hat ja aber die hat sich eine
maske pausen von 40 minuten also
offenbar ist dieses maske tragen auch
für erwachsene etwas was sie eigentlich
ungern tun was sie offenbar stört daniel
hain und wie passiert das bei kindern am
arbeitsplatz die müssen die ganze diese
weise getragen und das tun sie jetzt
seit bald zwei jahren also es ist jetzt
genau das was sie sagen das ist in zwei
sachen erstens ist es so dass die kinder
nie die treiber der pandemie waren das
ist wirklich so und die kinder wenn sie
sich erkranken haben auch mit den
schwereren varianten diesem anfang gab
haben die denn selbst in fällen schwerer
verläufe gehabt gibt es ganz wenig
todesfälle bei kindern das hat die
bild-zeitung übrigens sehr gut
recherchiert die zweite sache ist
bildung bildung geld für bildung das
heißt die das kind lernt nicht durch die
informations transfers sondern durch die
beziehung zu den lehrern und zu den
leuten die unterricht diese idee dann
wenn wir was gutes gelernt haben ist
dass dieser ganze distance-learning wie
wir das sagen nicht so gut funktioniert
und dass dieser diese emotionale anteil
der so wichtig ist für kinder völlig
verloren geht und wir können überhaupt
nicht ermessen gerade bei den kleinen
kindern wie jetzt die langfristige
psychologischen auswirkungen sein werden
dessen was wir jetzt die letzten zwei
jahre gemacht haben
die richtung ich frage mich oft auf
welcher grundlage dass mir denn jetzt
überhaupt noch die regierung
vorschreiben dass ich die maske tragen
muss ich zb hasse die maske für mich ist
es keine kleine einschränkung in mein
leben der sich mal mit diesen dingen
rumlaufen muss ja ich bin auch ich freue
mich jetzt auch nicht masken zu tragen
dass sich
das ist das schönste überhaupt aber noch
mal der punkt wenn man sich jetzt
entscheiden muss so sagen okay die stadt
da wollen wir dabei auf welcher auf
welcher grundlage digitalisierungsgrad
gerade kann es ja nicht sein
ja wobei die kann natürlich dann
teilweise ansteigen also was der henrik
strikt zb gestern sagte ich war ganz
spannendes gespräch deswegen will ich
mal wieder gehen weil ich ja nicht
virologe bin der sagt er geht davon aus
wir müssen noch ein paar wochen an der
masken pflicht festhalten danach kann
man auch die möglicherweise zurücknehmen
weil wir im frühjahr sommer natürlich
deutlich geringere zahlen namen als im
märz aber er geht auch davon aus dass
wir im nächsten herbst winter
möglicherweise auch wieder masken tragen
müssen weil die masten eben einen sehr
hohen effekt haben und ein
vergleichsweise gering eingriff
darstellt was ich wollte also weiß ich
werde noch einmal den punkt machen
weiter wenn das glaube ich ganz wichtig
ist dass wir unbedingt verhindern müssen
ist dass wir jetzt dauerhaft geschlossen
fußball stadien haben an den schulen sie
haben eben die situation beschrieben ich
teile das ja alles dass die
gewerbetreibenden teilweise nur sechs
sieben monate im jahr ihren beruf
nachgehen können einige jahre
mittlerweile seit über zwei jahren gar
nicht wirklich und da würde ich immer
sein wenn ist dann die maske uns alles
andere sichert kann man daran zumindest
teilweise noch festhalten im idealfall
haben wir aber bald auch gar keine
masten pflicht werden aber die maske ist
geschützt nur wenn die richtig also
rigoros getragen wird wenn sie richtig
angepasst wird und dann nur ein bisschen
also die die datenlage für das tragen
einer maske wie das im alltag passiert
ist mehr als dünn also und das würde ich
gerne sagt er also da haben mir jetzt
die virologen was anderes gesagt habt
ihr selber keinen forscher der studie
erstellt hat aber die sagten also der
effekt von massa sehr sehr hoch also
meinerseits selbstschutz angeht
andererseits auch was weitergabe des
virus angeht daher würde ich sagen ist
das jetzt nicht das hauptthema auf das
wir uns fokussieren heute in der bild
zeitung ich habe ja auch dazu stellung
genommen im sportteil war ja auch die
diskussion wie ausgelastet können die
fußballstadien sein und da wäre ich
immer der meinung die fußballstadion die
müssen jetzt voll da sein werden oder
zumindest voller aber da müssen wir
jetzt wirklich diskutieren das heißt die
kinder sollen weiter sechs stunden am
tag sieben habe ich gesagt in spanien
wollen wir aber öffnen das habe ich so
nicht gesagt habe doch nett gemeint aber
das ist die frage ich habe also wenn
sinn für den wert und die das gewerbe
wird geöffnet die stadien auch über die
kinder tragen weiter maske das kann doch
das passt doch nicht nur einen moment
ich bin ich bin der meinung also das
habe ich auch gesagt auch in den
diskussionen mit virologen in den
letzten tagen wie gesagt habe erwachsene
gehen ins restaurant die müssen die
maske kurz tragen auf dem weg zum platz
setzen sich hin teilweise mit zehn
leuten können die abnehmen fröhlich was
trinken und essen und die kinder fünf
sechs sieben stunden müssen was getragen
das finde ich geht auch nicht das heißt
wenn da so abstände eingehalten werden
wie in restaurants oder hygienische
standards gelten finde ich sollte noch
die kinder keine maske auf den platz
tragen müssen so das finde ich schon
deswegen unterstütze ich das aber wenn
man jetzt sagt okay man hat im
restaurant für 30 meter die maske auf
oder an den schulen kurz für fünf bis
zehn minuten und dafür sorgen wir dafür
dass es nicht so locker um maßnahmen
kommt und wer als koronaler wir uns
einigermaßen im griff haben könnte ich
mich in der abwägung noch damit
zufrieden das ist ja dass die maske das
den mond verdeckt aus verschiedenen
gründen sie haben professor strikt
zitiert aber wir wissen auch dass gerade
bei jungen schülern es extrem wichtig
ist dass sie sehen wie ihr neuer kein
lehrer spricht beispielsweise weil man
das am natürlich dann mit artikuliert
wenn es um fremdsprachen englisch
französisch ist es auch wieder extrem
wichtig dass man da nicht jemand vor
sich sitzen hat er eine maske trägt
sondern dass man das auch sieht wie wird
der grund höherer und sie bewegt sich in
der wundert ja haben sie auch recht ist
natürlich durch die maske auch nicht
immer gegeben also wir haben auch da bei
den möglicherweise wirklich dann auch
positiven effekten wie sie es gerade
beschrieben haben natürlich gleichzeitig
extrem negative effekte und wir müssen
da und das meine ich aus dem tiefsten
herzen meiner seele extrem schnell
zurück zu einer normalität kommen wir
kriegen sonst eine generation von
schülerinnen und schülern die wirklich
zurückbleiben stimme und er war ein ganz
ganz vielen punkten denn so eine maske
ist mehr als das sie nur einfach ich bin
eigentlich wollte anzeige eindruck
entsteht ich bin ja nicht dafür dass
kinder jugendliche zwölf stunden nur
nachts getragen ich hab immer selber
auch als einer der ersten in der debatte
darauf hingewiesen welche folgen corona
auch gerade für kinder und jugendliche
hat und habe immer gesagt gerade die
müssen in der debatte stärker
berücksichtigt werden mir ging es jetzt
darum wenn man sagt okay die müssen
vielleicht fünf oder zehn minuten eine
maske tragen es gilt ja für erwachsene
auch so ist ja keine seite nur für
kinder und jugendliche gelten soll
und dafür können sie aber normal zur
schule gehen dann wäre das für mich
schon okay da bleiben beim thema
comdirect ihn ich kann ihnen sagen liebe
zuschauer wir haben uns bei verachtender
reaktion auf die fahne geschrieben
weiter über die massen zu diskutieren
schicken sie uns auch gerne ihre
erlebnisse von ihren kindern jederzeit
zu ich bleibe weiterhin dabei dass ich
dagegen wenn wir gehen über zu ihm ja
also mein thema ist heute die spaltung
in der gesellschaft
und wir haben das jetzt nicht hier so
richtig erlebt habe man merkt dass
corona ein sehr aufgeheiztes thema ist
und das ist eine zu einer großen
spaltung vor allen dingen in der frage
kämpften ungeimpften welche rolle
spielen die ungeimpften an der pandemie
es sind die dafür schuld daran schuld
dass es dass es die diese hohe ident
zahlen gibt zum beispiel und an ein
thema was sich besonders ansprechen
möchte ist in diesem kontext die
nebenwirkungen weil es gibt eine sehr
aufgeheizte diskussion gerade was die
nebenwirkungen angeht die eine seite
sagt nebenwirkung fast jeder kriegt
nebenwirkung schwere nebenwirkungen
viele werden langfristig daran große
probleme bekommen die andere seite augen
sagt das gibt es nicht zum beispiel paul
ehrlich institut wenn man die
todeszahlen anguckt da haben wir
inzwischen 22 1000 verdachts-
todesmeldungen zusammen mit der impfung
ungefähr und das paul ehrlich institut
sagt davon sind ungefähr 80 gibt es
einen kausalen zusammenhang und die
anderen
1900 sind es statistische effekte so was
ist die wahrheit das wissen für licht
die wahrheit wird vielleicht wie immer
in solchen sachen irgendwo in der mitte
liegen und die frage ist wie er verfasst
man das und weil diese impfstoffe neu
sind weil sie sehr schnell entwickelt
worden sind die testung sehr schnell
gelaufen ist müsste man im prinzip jetzt
wo viele leute sich haben impfen lassen
im guten glauben müsste man eine eine
eine richtige verfassung machen dass man
die diese dieser nebenwirkung
systematisch erfasst in einer so
genannten kohortenstudie oder was
ähnliches das hat das wollte man bei
kurven am anfang machen es leider nicht
gemacht worden aber wir dürfen das kein
zweites mal verpassen dass wir eine
solche kohortenstudie dass wir eines
thematisch und lückenlose erfassung der
nebenwirkung auch über die jahre hinweg
jetzt bekommen und ich arbeite mit
anderen wissenschaftlern zusammen einer
initiative dass wir so was auf die beine
stellen es wäre auch natürlich super
wenn das paul-ehrlich-institut zum
beispiel eine solche initiative
unterstützen würde um vielleicht
einerseits die gruppe die sich haben
impfen lassen zu beruhigen dass es diese
nebenwirkungen doch nicht gibt in der
frequenz oder auf der anderen seite wenn
es dann tatsächlich schwere
nebenwirkungen gibt dass die
identifiziert werden auf dauer und da
glaube ich ist eine lücke die wir jetzt
schließen müssen herr professor sie
haben ja gleich zwei themenkomplexe
angesprochen einmal die kohorte an die
spaltung der gesellschaft ganz gerne
einfach zunächst einmal auf das erste
team spaltung der gesellschaft ihrer
antwort und bin nicht ihrer meinung und
trotzdem sind wir beide nicht und muss
hier keine risse insel nahe kommen
die spaltung hier findet in dem fall
nicht statt weil wir uns ja schätzen und
einfach ganz normal miteinander umgehen
ob julian ramm ein und das ist glaube
dann auch ganz wichtig genau und wenn
man und da würde ich ihm widersprechen
sich zahlen anschaut von umfragen
bertelsmann beispielsweise aber auch
konrad anheftung dann kommen die
umfragen ein ich zu einem anderen
ergebnis die kommt zum ergebnis dass die
zahl der menschen die sagen oh in diesem
land stehen wir unversöhnlich gegenüber
eher geschrumpft ist okay gut ja einer
gefahr ist also beispielsweise dieser
kanal an ausstellungen der wert von 4,1
prozent ist gesund auf einen 34 prozent
jetzt aktuell ja es heißt offenbar misst
damit unserer wahrnehmung etwas nicht
ganz richtig wenn wir von spaltung
sprechen vielleicht haben wir deutschen
auch zu lange in so einer angesagten
haase alle gelebt haben ja man muss gar
nicht mehr streiten angerissen ja wir
machen so ein bisschen näher und sind
alle happy und jetzt plötzlich schnell
wieder fest mensch es gibt ein thema was
uns total emotionalisiert und wir sind
einfach mal anderer meinung aber sehen
sie diese uns deswegen natürlich nicht
irgendwie mit hass und hetze ja das ist
richtig aber sind anderer meinung die
sie hat ihren seit auch ein bisschen
härter aber tauschen einfach mal meinung
aus gerade die waren thema im pflicht ja
aber nicht also ist es ist tatsächlich
so ich da gibt es ein widerspruch
auf der einen seite gibt es viele leute
die das persönlich nicht erleben habe
ich denke gerade einen artikel nicht
gelesen haben im fokus die letzten tage
wo
das ging mein patient der nicht geimpft
hat einen schwereren verlauf hatte im
krankenhaus und dann hat man ihn die
schuld gegeben für diesen verlauf da
habe sich nicht bedankt und dann gab es
viele kommentare unter diesem artikel
nicht geimpfte menschen die sonnen
höheren krankenkassenbeitrag wie soll
man nicht auf die intensivstation und
ich glaube das problem ist dass es in
der gesellschaft wahrscheinlich nicht so
präsent ist aber es gibt immer wieder in
den medien
er versuche eine solche spaltung zu
treiben und ich glaube so kommen wir
nicht weiter über das arbeiten an der
frage ob jemand der
höhere kosten verursachen das meine ich
jetzt ganz unabhängig aber jemand der
höhere kosten verursacht also ein
autofahrer beispielsweise der jeden
zweiten tag ein unfall macht der muss
natürlich eine höhere
versicherungsprämie bezahlt ist doch per
se erst mal nichts zu sagen deswegen
wenn man diesen vorschlag machen würde
darüber dass das würde ja das leitung
nichts zu tun da das würde ich nicht so
sehen also der arzt oder der der dass
das medizinische system aber der arzt
hat seine patienten immer zu behandeln
unabhängig davon ob er jetzt an dieser
erkrankung an der ursache der erkrankung
beteiligt das was ist mit menschen die
rauchen mit übergewicht menschen
menschen mit diabetes man muss jeden
menschen gleich behandeln völlig
unabhängig was seine herkunft ist was
aber schuld hatte diese schuldfrage
dürfen wir uns gar nicht stellen weil
wenn wir das anfangen zu stellen wo
hören wir damit auf und das ist glaube
ich schon ein schwieriges problem wie
hol mal eben dies oft klaus rein ich
wollte was ganz am anfang waren zum
thema spaltung der gesellschaft und fand
ganz interessant auch was sie gesagt
haben schäfer das einerseits ja die
gesellschaft sogar zusammengeführt wurde
durch ko und bei einigen fragen aber was
wird trotzdem aussehen müssen da gab es
zum beispiel vor einigen monaten eine
ganz spannende 1 bar umfrage hat das
verstanden dass immer mehr menschen in
deutschland sagen ja es gibt
meinungsfreiheit aber man kann nicht
mehr alles aussprechen weil man
befürchten muss man wird sozial
stigmatisiert in irgendeiner ecke
gestellt wenn man zum beispiel
irgendwelche ängste äußert
das thema migration da gibt es einige
mal an die sana ich weiß nicht was
passiert dann wird das gerne ansprechen
ohne dass das jetzt nazis sind und den
wird immer gleich was unterstellt und
das ist brandgefährlich für eine
gesellschaft weil die menschen dann was
unterdrücken nicht mehr auf freisprechen
und am ende sich das häufig auch in den
wahlkabinen entlädt und wir haben so was
ja in anderen ländern auch gesehen
großbritannien haben wir ganz am anfang
erwähnt aber vor allem auch die usa dann
gibt's ja diese sogenannte wok
netzbewegung wir kommen ja nachher
glaube ich auch noch mal darauf zu
sprechen und immer mehr personen die
sagen ja die menschen seien gewisse
gruppen einsortiert werden es gibt
vorgaben was man vielleicht noch sagen
davon denken darf und dass sorgt am ende
dafür dass der unmut in der gesellschaft
wächst das frust wächst und dass sich
das irgendwann entlädt und im
schlimmsten fall den populisten am
linken und rechten rand entstehen und
das müssen wir in deutschland verändern
deswegen muss diese studie von 1 bach
wirklich alle in der politik und in der
gesellschaft noch unter 50 prozent der
deutschen die hat hagen nein wenn ich
sehr kräftig im kopf wir hatten zweimal
60er 70er jahre maniche 6 prozent der
deutschen die gesagt hatten man kann
nicht immer alles aussprechen also eine
sehr geringe zahl um mittlerweile sind
wir laut allensbach bei über 50 prozent
ist seit 1953 der schlechteste wert muss
man dazu aussagen die studie öffentlich
rechtlicher sehr gerne weil ich werde
das ist wirklich die spaltung ist schon
so aufzeigt bei viktor team war schon
der perfekte bei zu dir übergeworfen wie
ist es denn so in england in
großbritannien wie würdest du die
spaltung einschätzen was dort studiert
sie ist nicht so groß wie in deutschland
denn das problem in deutschland sind
auch zum teil die medien ich darf mal
erinnern an diese silvesternacht als
zehn tage lang keiner wusste was
passiert war denn es gab keine
informationen und die medien hatten sich
sozusagen so eine mauer des schweigens
aufgebaut und haben nicht kommuniziert
darüber was da wirklich passiert ist und
sie haben es vorhin angesprochenen
migrationshintergrund in köln oder wer
genau für genau die java problem hat
wild hat schon am zweiten tag darüber
sehr ergiebig gefehlt hat berichtet aber
die meisten leute wussten tagelang nicht
die leute die nicht gelesen wussten
nicht was passiert war und dann als es
dann drauf kam hatten sie das gefühl wir
wurden hier tagelang im dunkeln gelassen
und das macht was mit der
meinungsfreiheit das macht was damit
dass man nicht mehr das gefühl hat dass
ehrlich mit einem umgegangen wird ich
weiß was du etwas meint ich war in
london kürzlich hat eine engländerin zu
mittag eine deutsche die in england lebt
hat sie gesagt warum verbreitete medien
eigentlich so eine panik meine eltern
die haben wirklich richtig angst und ich
sage immer in england gab es von anfang
an unterschiedliche standpunkte wie
würden sie das denn einschätzen hat das
vielleicht was damit zu tun dass man
vielleicht auch nur gefühlt die spaltung
der gesellschaft mehr fühlen also eben
eigentlich glaube schon dass es dass es
eine spaltung gibt und ich glaube ich
bin nicht nicht ganz ihrer meinung ich
glaube schon dass an dieser corona frage
wie gerade mit den ungeimpften
umgegangen wurde wie sie wie das
thematisiert wurde in den medien habe
ich habe diesen focus artikel vorhin
erwähnt ist wirklich unfair und
ungerecht weil es ist ja so dass sie
diese eine impfung jede medizinische
jeden fall mal jeder medizinische
intervention setzt die einwilligung des
patienten voraus ich darf den patienten
nicht behandelter patient nicht das
nicht will auch wenn es jetzt zu seinem
guten wenn seine eine richtige
behandlung ist die er braucht und er
möchte die behandlung nicht haben dann
darf ich ihnen nicht behandeln sonst
einer körperverletzung und das ist ein
ganz wichtiges prinzip in der mitte
ziehen und wir wir haben uns ein stück
weit doch darüber hinweggesetzt und dann
haben wir auch noch die die personen die
sich dann aus welchem grund auch immer
gegen eine impfung entschieden haben
doch ein stück weit stick signalisiert
und das sehe ich schon als problem okay
sie reden jetzt über die spaltung der
gesellschaft die wir vorgenommen haben
weil wir zwischen die impfung gegen ok
entschuldigung das habe ich
nicht
verstanden werden
ihnen um den austausch
wichtig vielleicht zu unterscheiden also
es kann ja sein das haben sie im jahr
auch gesagt dass man sagt es gibt
vielleicht die eine hälfte die die sie
das so im land und die andere hälfte
sieht es anders als in großbritannien
erlebt bei der bread abstimmung war fast
50 5 wenn das aber auf augenhöhe
diskussion gibt und man sagt man
akzeptiert auch die meinung des anderen
wir stimmen dann irgendwann ab und
akzeptieren das ergebnis muss das ja
nicht für eine gespaltene gesellschaft
rechnen da im gegenteil das kann sogar
eine demokrat tische gesellschaft
auszeichnen sind in der fraktion
wir sind mittlerweile wieder sehr sehr
einig
sie sind wir weit entfernt aber das ist
wichtig und dann kann es auch nicht
gesellschaft kann aber auch gespalten
seien man sagt 80 prozent versuchen 20
prozent zu unterdrücken oder die
auszugrenzen dann war da noch der
brechen lehrstück der demokratie denn
die hälfte kann man das kann man so
sehen ja weil man sagt alle akzeptieren
es danach und das war aus meiner sicht
so oder so wirklich sehr viele gesagt
haben okay ist jetzt abgestimmt worden
deswegen muss das nicht für eine
spaltung sprechen völlig richtig und
worum es mir ja eben gegen war dass man
viele den eindruck haben sie können
nicht mehr alles aussprechen können
nicht mehr alle ängste artikulieren und
das ist auf dauer sehr schlecht für eine
demokratie und das sehen wir vor allem
in den usa auch wohin das führt und gibt
ja viele weitere beispiele dass einige
sah ich trau mich vielleicht gar nicht
mehr zu sagen
eskimo indianer oder wörter die
eigentlich zu unserem sprachgebrauch ist
doch schon so ne sich eine untersagung
ganz gut stellen ich habe schon das
gefühl gehabt in letzteren dass jemand
der sich gegen die impfung entschieden
ist nicht gerne gemacht hat und auch
hier in den runden da muss ich auch
nicht haben wir immer betont wir sehen
das so aber ich bin dreifach geimpft und
hab den booster ausstand es hat man
wirklich immer dazu gesagt aus angst vor
kritik ich habe das auch gemacht ich
habe immer meinen status betont das
mache ich jetzt uns nicht mehr sie mich
eine persönliche entscheidung ich werde
ist nicht mehr da sagst du dreimal
wurde allerdings schon öffentlich hier
mehrfach zu weit wenn ich meine das ist
eigentlich eine für mich ist es eine
total persönliche entscheidung ist dass
man hat ja auch nicht früher ich hab
doch nicht früher wenn wir uns erst mal
begegnet sind ein impfausweis rausgeholt
in der zeitung sagt jack mal geführt
dagegen war sich alles geben und ist das
nicht schon problem geworden finde ich
als das ist also nach es ist diese
moralische überladung einer
medizinischen frage und das und diese
schuld da kommt diesen schuld aspekt
rein und er gehört überhaupt nicht in
die medizin rein diese dass man eine
schuld basierte sicht auf medizin da
müssen das müssen wir wirklich vermeiden
ja er hat sie gerade krankenversicherung
funktionieren bisschen anders wissen sie
finde ich dauernd zum arzt gehe habe ich
einen deutlich höheren beitrag dann da
wird schon geguckt welches risiko habe
ich also die private krankenversicherung
arbeitet natürlich und das ist glaube
ich vollkommen richtig mit einem anreiz
mechanismus und sagt wenn du der meinung
bist du muss was ganz gefährliches
machen die ganze zeit dann verursachte
höhere kosten und warum soll die
allgemeinheit dafür bezahlen wenn du
privat sagst ich will aber wenn ich alle
sind unglaublich ganz gut aber wenn der
skifahrer zum dritten mal in der in der
notaufnahme auftaucht mit seinem
beinbruch darf der arzt nicht sagen oder
böse ski fahre ich habe eigentlich nicht
nein sondern muss ihn genauso vorsichtig
hier auch nicht passiert also da muss
man ich glaube es gibt nur einen
unterschied bei der debatte da will ich
mal hier alleine in der runde gegen alle
argumentieren bei den zum nächsten thema
ankommen dann beim nächsten mal dann
ganz schnell bei den skifahrern haben
wir nie die diskussion gibt es wegen zu
vieler skifahrer eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems die hatten wir vor
ein paar monaten mit blick auf zu viele
ungeimpfte und da haben natürlich viele
geimpfte gesagt wir können jetzt nicht
wochenlang in einloggt darum gehen mit
einschränkungen leben und möglicherweise
droht eine überlastung des gesammelt
sondern die 3d center kann austreten ja
machen deswegen ist das ist das schon
anders gelagert bei der diskussion um im
geimpft und nicht geimpfte und auf der
anderen seite skifahrer oder raucht aber
wenn man nur vier prozent der
intensivbetten 2020 waren mit krone
patienten belegt 96 prozent der in der
siebten waren nicht willig rede jetzt
mal habt ihr können auf machen erwähnen
die recherche von tim rühren das ist ein
welt kollege der der viel darüber
intensivbetten rationiert und wir gehen
weiter zu jan schäfer ja ein thema
abseits von corona das hat zu tun mit
der bundesregierung mit der neuen
bundesregierung und mit dem ein oder
anderen was sich in den ersten noch
nicht einmal 100 tagen doch an
merkwürdigen dingen da zugetragen hat
und da komme ich auf beispielsweise
eine außenministerin die die greenpeace
chefin direkt in ihr engstes umfeld rot
und zur
staatssekretären quasi befördert einen
staatssekretär im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bei robert
habeck der direkt von einem grünen think
tank kommt also purer lobbyismus in der
bundesregierung wir haben eine
umweltministerin die
protest die einfach unangemeldeten
protest auf autobahnen als legitimes
mittel des zivilen ungehorsams geradezu
lobt eine parteivorsitzende ricaner lang
von den grünen die das ähnlich sieht er
musste erst der bundesjustizminister
kommen und sagen mit der peitsche quasi
dazwischen ein unrecht ist unrecht und
ziviler ungehorsam kann kein mittel sein
also wir sehen dass in schulen
mittlerweile abgefragt wird welche co2
footprint auch sechs oder siebtklässler
bereits hinterlassen also was ich hier
feststellung was ich sagen muss ist das
land wird mir zu grün ich bin ein großer
großer anhänger von klimaschutz aber
wenn ich auch sehr mit welchem werk und
welchem enthusiasmus jetzt das land ich
sags ganz plakativ zugekleistert werden
soll mit beispielsweise
windrädern mit
solaranlagen auf allerbeste ackerfläche
dann finde ich das extrem bedenklich und
muss noch einmal die warnung aussprechen
das land wird mir zu gründen
also das land darf zumindest politisch
auf keinen fall grün oder noch grüner
werden denn in der tat merken wir an
ganz vielen beispielen dass es dem land
nicht gut tut ich finde übrigens auch
nicht dass man sagen sollte wer die
grünen wähle der macht was gutes für den
klimaschutz denn das gegenteil ist der
fall wir werden nur erfolgreich
klimaschutzpolitik machen können wenn
wir das erstens international angehen
allein die chinesen und die usa stoßen
das x-fache aus von deutschland wir sind
ungefähr zwei prozent der weltweiten co2
emissionen verantwortlich aber selbst
wenn wir alles hier auf null fahren die
musterknaben der welt werden eher würden
wir das weltklima nicht retten deswegen
wird das nur international funktionieren
und wir werden natürlich auch nur die
menschen für klimaschutz begeistern wenn
es nicht zu sozialen verwerfungen kommen
zur sozialen einschränkungen und wenn
man zum beispiel sagt okay wir wollen
dass sie auch in zukunft mein urlaub
fliegen könnt aber wie sollen dafür dass
fliegen klimaneutral wird und deswegen
sind die ansätze der grünen er für die
klimaschutzziele schädlich und wir
bräuchten mehr bürgerliche politik und
das bedeutet auf innovation zu setzen
auch soziale marktwirtschaft auf
erfindungen mit denen wir immer mehr co2
reduzieren
und noch ein punkt machen weil der ist
ganz wichtig
die grünen messen immer mit zweierlei
maß die kritisieren wenn irgendwo aus
der wirtschaft jemand in die politik
geht in einem ministerium geht dann ist
der aufschrei recht groß sie selber
holen sich von greenpeace und von
anderen organisationen die leute und
sagen das ist völlig normal und bejubeln
das noch und ich finde es richtig dass
auch quereinsteiger in die politik gehen
und dann muss das auch für alle anderen
gelten und da dürfen die grünen nicht
mit so einer doppelmoral unterwegs sein
wir haben es ja mit einer absoluten
verschiebung auch von normen und von
werten zu tun das meinte ich gerade mit
dem thema auch ziviler ungehorsam über
die energiefrage kann man auch
sicherlich nochmal komplett gesondert
diskutieren vollkommen richtig aber das
thema ziviler ungehorsam das wird jetzt
stilisiert zu etwas ganz normalem zu
etwas quasi fast notwendigen aber nur
wenn es um das thema klimaschutz geht
ich möchte mal wissen was passiert mit
dem extra jetzt dieses radikale beispiel
auch wenn sich nicht sagt ganz bewusst
nazis auf einer autobahn hinsetzen und
den verkehr blockieren da wäre zu recht
da wäre zu recht in diesem land ganz
ganz viel los ich sage nochmal zu recht
und wenn's klima so genannte
klimaaktivisten machen dann stellt sich
die umweltministerin hin und sagt ja ist
doch gar nicht in ordnung und die
parteivorsitzende einer regierungspartei
sagt auch die story nicht in ordnung ist
sie wieder ungehorsam ja also wo kommen
wir hin wenn das jeder für sich in
anspruch nimmt und damit meint die
öffentliche ordnung außer kraft setzen
zu können dann wird deutschland ein
tollhaus und die justizministerin hat ja
so die ministerin hat ja sogar getweetet
man kann seine meinung auch von zuhause
kundtun gab einen kleinen skandal der
hatte aber nicht größer sein müssen denn
die leute die für scream auf die straße
gehen da ist es dann in ordnung verstehe
ich nicht was genau der punkt also und
das ist dass da wo wir aufpassen müssen
dass da gerade dieser regierung nicht
gewisse dinge sich verschieben und zwar
von oben
oktroyiert also das aus mit regierungs
zustand immer schlimmer das war ja
normal hätte eine unnütz ministerin wie
frau lemke von den grünen sagen müssen
also das was da einige machen mit
autobahn blockaden die sorgen dafür dass
kannten waren gar nicht mehr durchfahren
können das können der rechtsstaat nicht
akzeptieren da muss der rechtsstaat
konsequent vorgehen so wie man das bei
allen anderen ja auch macht und da sagen
die nahe dass vielleicht eine
organisation die uns nahe steht und dann
ist man mit zweierlei maß und das ist am
ende auch sehr gefährlich für die
demokratie und den rechtsstaat denn der
rechtsstaat und die demokratie zeichnen
sich dadurch aus dass für alle die
gleichen regeln gelten und nicht für
eine gruppe irgendwelche sonderregeln
und man müsste ja sonst auch irgendwann
sagen wenn vielleicht irgendwelche leute
im rechtspopulistischen bereich am
rechten rand ich bin weit davon entfernt
aber nehmen wir mal an es gibt so eine
gruppe und die sagten wir beanspruchen
solche rechte auch die dürfen das auch
da kann man ganz schwer argumentieren
dass die das recht nicht haben und dann
wird es sehr gefährlich und deswegen
muss man sagen es gibt ja aus guten
gründen demonstrationsrecht man kann
protestieren aber alle müssen sich an
dieselben spielregeln halten der zivile
ungehorsam der wird jetzt muss man dann
sagen zum bibelwort das wird jeder
nutzen der lust auf ein bisschen randale
hat und vergessen hat oder gar beute
diese demonstration der macht irgendwo
anzumelden ganz klar auch nochmal
zusagen für mehr klimaschutz zu
protestieren ist total gut und macht
wahrscheinlich auch ganz viel sinn die
frage ist immer wie mache ich das und
wenn ich einfach autobahn besetze damit
mich selbst gefährde aber autofahrer
gefährde und einfach den stempel
draufdrücken ja das ist doch jetzt
ziviler ungehorsam bin ich hier tätige
dann geht das natürlich überhaupt nicht
umweltministerin nennt gehabt er dann
auch noch ein ddr vergleichen hier
situation herbei gezogen und hat das ja
auch relativiert das muss man
fairerweise sagen aber gesagt der ddr
gab es ja auch zivile ungehorsam jeder
muss sich einfach sagen das sind maß und
mitte komplett verloren gegangen aber
einer umweltminister rente also dass ich
das mal keine demokratie na ja das
wollte ich sagen also diese fragen
werden sehr stark
moralisiert einerseits und wir verlieren
auch hier ein bisschen maß und mitte wie
teilweise vorhin jetzt mit corona das
ist eigentlich dass man muss man muss zu
einer vernünftigen
diskurs kultur kommen und hier ist es
halt so dass ein es gibt gute
demonstration und schlechte
demonstration in einem kontext ist eine
sache erlaubt seinem anderen für anderes
ist nicht erlaubt und das das ist auf
dauer ersetzen würde ich fast sagen für
die für die für die demokratie und ich
würde ja noch an sache erzählen und zwar
gab es eine mitarbeiterin der damaligen
staatssekretärin für digitalisierung
dorothee bär diese frau ist aus diverse
büros direkt zu facebook gegangen als
lobbyist denn da haben die grünen sich
wahnsinnig aufgeregt habe ein riesen auf
schreibt vielleicht auch zu recht beweis
dafür gibt es regeln die muss man
einhalten aber jetzt wo jennifer morgen
kommt alles in ordnung ja man stelle
sich vor man stellt sich vor von einem
automobilen nahen winkte oder im
institut würde ja der chef die chefin
hat die leute geht schildert er wäre ja
wahnsinn da irgendwie das wird das land
würde bei mir gar keine normale sendung
machen will alles wackelt und zwar immer
noch nie wieder so aber
in dem fall und das ist glaube ich etwas
was
wir gerade als journalisten auch immer
extrem gut im blick haben müssen was
glaube ich aber auch ein gesellschaft
insgesamt immer im blick haben muss
messen wir eigentlich mit zweierlei maß
oder essen messen wir mit dem gleichen
maß und
wer etwas in anspruch nimmt für sich
muss dieses recht auch wenn es die
andere seite aus anderen dinge ausnutzt
muss es dem anderen auch zugestehen aber
hätte die union denn jetzt eigentlich
die ampel gemacht also hätte die union
mit den grünen auch gerne
die jamaika oder soja bei der ampel sind
wir noch nicht
also ich habe immer gesagt wenn ich
gesagt nein sie würden nicht mehr den
namen aber nicht ich habe nicht gesagt
ich habe immer gesagt wenn wir gewählt
werden dann sollten wir auch alles dafür
tun unsere punkte umzusetzen dafür
werden wir gewählt die leute sagen ja
nicht super die wollen sich dann
irgendwo entspannt dahin setzen und
einfach nur ein paar parolen raushauen
sondern ich habe gesagt wir müssen
versuchen jamaika hinzubekommen
natürlich nicht um den preis der
selbstaufgabe aber die debatte hatte
sich ja relativ schnell selbst erledigt
weil die fdp dann gesagt hat auch wenn
man das doch am liebsten mit spd und
grünen genau und dementsprechend haben
wir jetzt hier die ampel in deutschland
und gleich geht's weiter nach der
werbung mit 2 die finnen noch sehr
spannenden themen und sprechen darüber
was dr christoph ploß eigentlich gerade
also da kann ich ein lauter frauen nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren sind für die nach 87 tagen der
schlagen sein machen mein name zähler
so nicht
retten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße ruhen die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zugewandt lasst den leuten noch mal
den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich vertraulich sind der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig gerufen
das vorliegen eines quasi zum manko
bleibt einmal kurz ein dass also immer
noch das ist übliche andrack trainer
ausgesprochen ich habe meinen beifall um
eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
sich darum niemand ist button fehlten
man muss das ganz kleine auch darüber
sprechen ganz einfach nicht wer sich
richtig ist die karte mädchen nicht mehr
glauben nur noch vier tore
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und wir wollen
selbstverständlich wie immer keine zeit
verlieren und dr christoph ploß fährt
direkt vor ort
an der grenze zur ukraine droht
kriegsgefahr und nachdem schon russland
vor einigen jahren in teile der ukraine
einmarschiert ist gibt es jetzt weitere
drohungen dass die russen in weitere
gebiete gehen und weitere teile der
ukraine annektieren gerade jetzt
bräuchte es eine klare haltung der spd
die die deutsche bundesregierung anführt
aber wir müssen feststellen die spd hat
ihren moralischen kompass bei der
sogenannten russland frage verloren olaf
scholz nimmt neben joe biden nicht mal
das wort nord stream 2 in den mund
obwohl der us präsident dass werden
einer pressekonferenz klar artikuliert
und auch die internationalen partner
erwarten dass wir ein signal setzen nord
stream 2 ist erledigt wenn russland in
weitere teile der ukraine einmarschiert
ähnliches gilt für manuela schwesig die
bei vielen gelegenheiten sagt nord
stream 2 soll in betrieb genommen werden
und die geschehnisse in russland bei 4
in pressekonferenzen und öffentlichen
auftritten nicht wirklich erwähnt und es
gibt weitere personen an der spitze der
spd der fraktionsvorsitz wolf mützenich
ist da zu nennen aber natürlich auch
altbundeskanzler gerhard schröder der
mittlerweile zu einem global ssten von
wladimir putin geworden ist und ich kann
die spd nur auffordern zeigen sie eine
klare haltung bei der russland frage
davon hängt der frieden in europa ab
aber davon hängt auch das ansehen
deutschlands gegenüber unseren
internationalen partnern ab so wie es
derzeit in der spd läuft kann es nicht
mehr weitergehen
hier habe ich direkt eine nachfrage herr
doktor platzes sie es heute sich noch
trauen sich so zu äußern haben sie nicht
angst dass sie wieder anwaltspost von
frau schwesig nach hause gekommen das
richtig habe ich vor einigen tagen
bekommen wegen auch kritische äußerungen
zur frau schwesig bei einer anderen
talkshow und ich kann nur sagen ich
lasse mich davon nicht einschüchtern und
ich lasse mich auch davon nicht mundtot
machen weil ich es enorm wichtig finde
dass gerade wie auch als opposition im
deutschen bundestag deutlich machen dass
die spd bei der russland frage kein
klarer kurs hat und dass das was viele
spd-politiker derzeit äußern ist völlig
unterschiedlich deutschlands ansehen
schadet deswegen kann ich nur ein sagen
ich bleibt weiter dran und sie waren
nicht erstarren ich meine wenn man die
anwaltspost aufmacht und plötzlich ja
ich war schon erstaunt weil das auch
gerade unter kollegen in der politik aus
meiner sicht nicht der normale weg ist
und auch ist sich normalerweise so
gehört dann ruft man vielleicht mal an
und sagt hat die äußerung fand ich jetzt
nicht okay dann klärt man das beim bier
oder bei einem telefonat und in der
regel ist auch gut es handelt sich ja um
eine kritische aussage aber natürlich
nicht um eine beleidigung das wäre auch
gar nicht mein stil und deswegen muss
ich sagen hat dieses verhalten mich doch
etwas befremdlich gestimmt das zeigt
dass die spd jetzt wie ein
aufgescheuchtes re im moment weil diese
assoziation mit schröder so schwierig
ist dass ich habe heute die
presskonferenz von scholz und pushen
angeschaut und er hat zweimal gesagt ich
habe den größten respekt für gerhard
schröder und stolz neben ihm ist
erzittert und man dachte oh gott diese
parteien wenn man ganz bei ihnen ja ja
das ist ja auch vor allem nicht
besonders souverän
also wenn man gleich sagt arman droht
mit einer klage und schaltete die
anwälte ein also ich versuche immer
andere wege zu finden und auf heute um
das noch mal zu vervollständigen in
dieser pressekonferenz ja gesagt von
einem wert von einem ehemaligen
politiker gesprochen und meinte
eigentlich den altbundeskanzler oder wie
heißt es korrekt bundeskanzler gerhard
schröder also der eigene parteifreund
wurde von olaf scholz heute in dieser
pressekonferenz putin über dann als
ehemaliger politiker bezeichnet viel
größer hätte watsch'n gar nicht
ausfallen können und das ist nichts für
die missachtung genommen hat auch gesagt
er spricht nicht für die bundesregierung
ich stimme ihnen in vielen dingen zu
airplus was ihre abrechnung gerade auch
mit dem kurs der spd in der russland
frage an gegen heute bei dem auftritt
von olaf scholz im kreml muss ich sagen
war das schon ziemlich souverän was olaf
scholz da hingelegt hat und das war auch
ziemlich deutlich bei allen
diplomatischen floskeln dies daniel noch
gibt war ziemlich deutlich
auch im ton aber
was mich so ein bisschen hier umtreibt
und die spd hat ja auch einen starken
flügel der aus der friedensbewegung
kommt ich frage mich schon seit tagen wo
bleiben eigentlich die ganzen
demonstrationen
vor der russischen botschaft hier in
berlin vor den russischen konsulaten und
zwar die demonstration der
friedensaktivisten die ja sobald amerika
irgendwo nur möglicherweise sich
einschalten möchte militärisch um
freiheit zu verteidigen direkt auf die
straße gehen und demonstrieren ami go
home aber wenn der aggressor wladimir
putin die ukraine zusätzlich also noch
mal stärker unter seine kontrolle
bringen möchte dann ist hier auf diesen
straßen quasi gehen die lehrer sind die
friedensaktivisten alle zu hause liegen
in den betten oder schauen verdacht bei
bild das ist einerseits gut weil
einerseits
die gucken auch noch mit ca das ist toll
dass geringverdiener sagen ja mit bezug
auf klimaschutz vorher oder nachher
könnten sie demonstrieren gehen das wäre
wichtig um überhaupt glaubwürdigkeit zu
haben ein friedensaktivist ist nur dann
glaubwürdig wenn er jetzt gegen putin
demonstriert wenn nicht ist ja nicht
glaubwürdig
ja ich habe eine nur eine frage zu den
nord stream zwei wie wie abhängig sind
wir von diesem pipeline oder wie
abhängig werden wir dann wenn nordteams
zwei online käme dass wir sehr gute
frage man kann glaube ich klar sagen es
wird sehr teuer die usa haben dazu
gesagt sie würden dann flüssiggas
liefern aber ist dass im transport viel
teurer als gas über eine pipeline und
die frage ist auch gibt es dann
ausreichend mengen und wenn es nicht
ausreichend mengen gibt dann steigt
natürlich automatisch auch der preis
in den vergangenen jahren das muss man
auch ehrlicherweise sagen sind in der
energiepolitik aus meiner sicht einige
fehler gemacht worden man hätte zum
beispiel nicht erst aus der kernkraft
aussteigen sollen und dann aus der kohle
sondern wir hätten auf kernkraft so wie
andere länder auch setzen sollen und
gleichzeitig auch auf den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien das meyer von
finnland bis frankreich über viele
osteuropäische staaten ganz viele andere
nachbarn in europa und daher ist das
natürlich schon ein gewisser harakiri
kurs und sagt man geht aus kernkraft
draußen gehen aus kohle raus
gleichzeitig gibt es probleme mit dem
gas und man hat sich noch bei dieser
geopolitischen lage in gewisser weise
von russland abhängig gemacht ich habe
immer auch davor gewarnt und glaube dass
das nicht der richtige weg ist aber man
kann auch nicht sagen man setzt sich für
eine stärkung des völkerrechts ein und
man sagt wir stehen auch partnern wie
der ukraine bei wenn russland mit
weiteren überfällen droht aber sagen das
geht aber dann nicht mehr wenn wir
irgendwo wirtschaftliche folgen spüren
ich bin erstaunt und muss sagen ein
bisschen auch befremdet darüber wie groß
doch der antiamerikanismus auf der einen
seite hier in deutschland ist also nicht
mal jeder zweite bundesbürger sagt nach
studien dass amerika also unser starker
partner ist da sind wir in europa
tabellenletzter aber es gibt eine sehr
sehr große neigung hinzu wladimir putin
und das ist doch muss ich sagen ehrlich
gesagt sehr erstaunlich also wenn man
das jetzt mal ganz stark schwarz weiß
malt dann sehen wir doch wo die freiheit
zu hause ist und wo die freiheit nicht
zu hause ist und wie kann ein land dass
amerika extrem viel zu verdanken hat
eigentlich den wichtigsten den besten
und den stärksten partner den wir haben
so immer wieder vor den kopf stoßen wie
kann es auch die spd übrigens und die
kammer daran arbeitet er gerade die spd
deswegen auch mal eine scharfe kritik an
der spd wenn man sich gestern zum
beispiel rolf mützenich anschaut im ard
morgenmagazin dann spricht der
angesichts der tatsache dass
hunderttausende russische soldaten die
ukraine umzingelt haben auch noch davon
das ist berechtigte
sicherheitsinteressen russlands gibt
natürlich hat russland
sicherheitsinteresse und es gibt
berechtigte aber wenn man angesichts
dieser lage auch noch teilweise negative
von wladimir putin aufnimmt und die hier
in deutschland sträubt dann braucht man
sich nicht zu wundern dass sich auch der
anti amerikanismus ausbreitet und wir
waren immer in deutschland stark und
haben unsere sicherheit und freiheit
auch daraus gesorgt weil wir ein enges
bündnis mit amerika und dafür müssen wir
uns einsetzen und sie haben ein punkt
völlig zu recht gesagt ich sehe ja auch
viele demos da heißt dann immer ami go
home oder irgendwelche anderen parolen
ich sehe aber keine demos gegen china
menschenrechtsverletzung finden dort
statt die chinesen haben dich angemalt
bei mir in düssel aber gebe ich kaum in
deutschland
ausnahmen aber
wirklich immer immer immer einen
wahrscheinlich wirklich so formulieren
wir haben ja deutlich mehr
antiamerikanische demonstration und
parolen als demonstrationen gegen chinas
gewann auch gegen russland gewann und
das ist natürlich absolut falsch und
teilweise auch verlogen dann wir haben
ja diese pressekonferenz heute
hingesehen und das muss man auch sagen
hat olaf scholz schon gut immer wieder
pariert das war was mir putin dort zum
besten geboten hat zum teil also das
best of fake news also ja man hat er
wieder sprechen müssen er tat was zum
teil auf putin sprach einmal zum
beispiel vom genozid im jugoslawien oder
scholz gesagt hat dass dort im juli hat
gesagt es gab einen angriffskrieg ein
krieg der nato in jugoslawien oder
schulte nachfrage sagt wir waren dabei
wir sind aber in gewissen völkermord zu
stoppen was etwas völlig anderes ist ja
putin hatte hatte auch einige vergleiche
gebrachter mit dem genozid die nicht
okay waren und da hätte scholz aus
meiner sicht dann widersprechen müssen
ja aber faktum ist dass
putin ihr eine propagandashow auch heute
hat versucht wieder abzuziehen in die
olaf scholz doch durchaus immer wieder
reingegrätscht ist also das thema
jugoslawien die nato auch als angriffs
allianz darzustellen zeigt eigentlich
dass putin ahlmann ist er nur in krieg
und frieden denkt und der der nato
wirklich attestiert sie wäre genauso
aggressiv wie er das ist oder wie das
das sowjetreich war ist sie aber
natürlich nicht wissen wir ganz genau
von daher sind diese ganzen vergleiche
die er heute auch gezogen hat eigentlich
nur dazu da gewesen um noch mal zu sagen
warum er eigentlich in die ukraine
weiter einen riegel haben gegenüber nur
mit einer gewissen härte begegnen das
haben ja auch die vergangenen tage
gezeigt und diese härte liegt olaf
scholz im moment nicht an den tag er
sagt dann ergibt der ukraine ein
bisschen geld aber waffen kriegt die
ukraine nicht zur selbstverteidigung und
man will sogar und hatten daten aber das
muss ich ganz während sich die frage hat
nicht einmal nachgetreten hatte
bundeskanzlerin merkel die ja noch nicht
so lange aus und ist auch nie waffen an
die ukraine geliefert die frage hatte
sich damals noch nicht in der form
gestellt wie jetzt aber oder merkel sind
zb was man die peschmerga geliefertes
besetzt dass man sich wird aber die sind
damals also die waffen sind ja an die
peschmerga geliefert werden also und da
merkel ist da schon auch passiert ich
würde jetzt gerne noch viel länger an
dieses thema debattieren aber jeder von
uns hat er nun wisse sendezeit und nicht
das tun zu spät kommt zu kurz kommen
wird oder besser gesagt dementsprechend
regio ist mit dem thema mein thema fängt
an mit einem explizit hat mich von
nichts kommt nichts aus kann hier weiß
jeder lena du bist eine frau du sprichst
hier obwohl wir eine männerrunde sind
auch mit und ich finde das gut ich
glaube dass du das aus eigener kraft
tust ja denn mein thema ist eine regel
die das studentenparlament der
universität berlin der humboldt
universität berlin sprich 2018
ausgedacht hat und wir dürfen da jetzt
männer in debatten nur noch dann das
sagen wenn vorher eine frau gesprochen
hat wenn nur noch männer sich melden
dann darf keiner was sagen das gespräch
ist beendet ich glaube aber studieren
ist dafür da dass man denken lernt dass
man ein echten diskurs hat und ich
glaube diese regel ist komplett
verblendet wie viele andere in dieser
gender ideologie auch und damit bin ich
nicht einverstanden
viktor wachs da kann ich nur zustimmen
absolut applaus wenn das erlaubt wäre
hier oder ich mache es einfach absolut
richtig also dass ich ein parlament
eine regel auferlegt die die freie rede
quasi ausschließt wenn nur ein
bestimmter teil derjenigen die dort
teilnehmen oder im parlament sitzen mit
macht und das auch noch an geschlechtern
orientiert das ist das wäre wenn man das
überträgt in den bundestag
beispielsweise airplus oder auch in die
wissenschaft das wäre der tod dieser
demokratie so einfach muss man das sagen
es muss die möglichkeit geben
aufzustehen und was zu sagen es muss
auch die möglichkeit geben zu sagen ich
bin jetzt mal ruhig aber daran darf doch
eine debatte geführt wird nicht
scheitern oder
stattfinden das kann auch nicht das
kriterium sein also das ist so was von
mir fehlen die worte gestrig als
demokratiegefährdend es ist windig die
frauen frauen kann doch selber sich
durchsetzen und das das drückt den sohn
der heute zeigt dass in jeder jahre hier
sitzt jedoch nicht
unsere treffen mit dem sinne und sie
schafft es auch aber ich glaube dass die
geschlechter gar nicht so ein thema sein
sollten ob man jetzt männliches oder
weibliches deswegen bin ich auch sehr
gegen zu ändern weil da wird ja auch mal
gesagt du bist ein mann du bist eine
frau und ich finde es nicht ich glaube
schon dass wir mit blick auf die
gleichberechtigung noch eine einige
kämpfe zu kämpfen haben ich würde zum
beispiel begrüßen die frauenquote das
alles staatliche betrifft also ich finde
staatliche institutionen sollten quoten
einführen das ist staatlich wir sind so
und die privatbahnen genannt passiert so
was wir in paris ein tarif sogar frauen
dann nicht mehr in führungspositionen
die verwaltung weil schon zu frauen
gehabt ihrem qualitäts gesetze oder ist
jetzt müssen männer rein und bundestag
oder auf ich finde aber im bundestag und
da würde ja bedeuten die wählerinnen und
wähler haben nicht mehr die möglichkeit
frei zu wählen wenn wir sagen der
bundestag ist paritätisch das ja
übrigens auch das was die grünen
anstreben aber der ganzen gesellschaft
aber im moment aber das heißt dann
müsste man sagen ihr dürft jetzt nur
noch ein mann oder eine frau wählen wenn
wir jetzt alles marianne berger
ausgezeichnet doch die demokratie werden
muss sagt man muss auch sehen dass es
nicht nur eine parlaments sondern
universität auch noch obendrein genau
und es ist zum beispiel so von den
medien in der medizin humanmedizin es
ist bei den erstsemestern ist dass 75%
bis 80% der erstsemester studierenden
sind frauen inzwischen und das wird
langsam fast problem will ich nicht
sagen aber flüssig
da muss man einfach schade also da kann
man eine diskriminierung sage ich mal
schlecht aus machen und an der
universität gibt gibt es auch ein
parlament gibt es gerade die freie rede
und ich finde das gerät genau in diesem
kontext und überhaupt diese dieses also
kanzler culture wenn man das jetzt auf
macht das ganze gerade an den
universitäten ist eine sehr gefährliche
zu machen jetzt den ganzen anderen fass
auf aber das dürfen wir überhaupt nicht
weil das sind die anfänge die frage ist
nach welchen anderen kriterien will man
dann kann das nach geschlecht habe ich
kann ich kann mir vor anderen fünf oder
sechs andere kriterien die ich einführen
könnte und das kann ja nicht
funktionieren ist vor allem auch eine
fehlentwicklung also wenn wir sagen die
menschen definieren sich nicht mehr nach
leistung so oder nach dem was sie als
mensch ausmacht sondern in erster linie
zählt das geschlecht in erster linie
zählt der migrationshintergrund oder der
ort in dem du genau was er will
das alter ist hier die eventuell
sexuelle orientierung die wird
mittlerweile auch teilweise schon
abgefragt bei einigen kongressen und
beim essen sehen wir zum beispiel das
jetzt schauspieler nur noch eine rolle
spielen dürfen wenn sie dieselbe
sexuellen orientierung haben aus
derselben region kommen selben tage
seien habe und das ist auch unfair weil
dann heißt es ja okay die eine hälfte
kannte ich schon mal gar nicht um eine
position bewerben weil man in
anführungszeichen das falsche geschlecht
hat und deswegen müssen wir diesen
fehlentwicklungen mit aller
entschlossenheit entgegen treten oder am
ende gar man die poeten die bei der
einführung von joe biden dieses tolle
gesicht auf englisch vorgetragen hat die
sollte das auf deutsch publizierten dann
gab es eine übersetzerin und die war
nicht der teil der gleichen ebene und
dann wurde das unterbunden und jetzt
gibt es das deutsche die deutsche
version immer noch nicht fertig es ist
natürlich quatsch auch was dort an der
universität passiert aber ich glaube man
machte sich immer sehr einfach indem man
dann alles also alles was total wir ist
finde ich auch alles wir die
angesprochenen beispiele durch möchte
man also und sagt man muss gar nichts
mehr tun und das sehe ich anders hat
können auch wenn der frauenanteil in der
union ich kann jetzt gar nicht genau
sagen wie wir dadurch auch jeden prozent
unter 40 denke ich ist er in der
fraktion aber auch das war ja eine freie
entscheidung der wählerinnen und wähler
das ist ja nicht so dass irgendjemand
das vorgegeben hat ich bin ja zum
beispiel gewählt worden ich nicht soll
ich mich jetzt für mein geschlecht
entschuldigen
die unterlagen aber was ich bin da auch
es ist ein falscher ansatz zu sagen wir
machen von anfang an wollen wir ergebnis
gleichheit und alles soll gleich sein
was viel wichtiger ist dass alle die
gleichen rechte und gleiche chancen
haben das kann dann am ende zur
ungleichen ergebnissen führen aber
entscheidend ist dass alle gleiche
rechte und 2000 haben quoten in freundin
war wenn das das ergebnis freie
entscheidung ist ist das doch auch
unproblematisch ich möchte aber trotzdem
den frauenanteil höhen und was glaube
ich ganz wichtig ist in dem zusammenhang
und viel wichtiger als quoten dass zum
beispiel die vereinbarkeit von familie
und beruf deutlich verbessert wird denn
ich sehe zum beispiel auch bei mir in
meiner generation zwischen 30 und 40 da
sind viele gut ausgebildete frauen nicht
sie haben eben erwähnt gerade im bereich
medizin deutlich mehr frauen als männer
und die haben auch häufig bessere noten
und wenn die dann kinder bekommen haben
dann ist das häufig ein karriereknick
und daran müssen wir arbeiten das stimmt
aber das wollen wir nicht über
gleichmacherei und quoten erreichen aber
ist ja indem wir zum beispiel sehr gute
betreuungsangebote
garantieren es gibt zum beispiel jetzt
meine ich sogar an einigen universitäten
in münchen meine ich eine fast 24
stunden kita es gibt die möglichkeit
dass sich zum beispiel gerade auch für
ärzte angerechnet wird wenn kinder
pausen oder babypausen und das sind
glaube ich die richtigen wege die wir
auch in viele andere teile der
gesellschaft übertragen müssen damit
frauen nicht sagen entscheide ich mich
für ein kind oder entscheide ich mich
für eine krise würde die frage
aufstellen wollen wir dann in der
medizinmänner quote einführen
wenn wir jetzt wenn also es ist ja so es
gibt berufe ist eine quote ineinander
aber der lehre berufen war einmal ein
männlicher beruf ist jetzt fast sicher
ist er selber wie pastoren evangelische
pastoren ist auch so die frage ist in
der medizin ich halte das für eine sehr
ungesunde entwicklung wo wir nur männer
oder nur frauen hätten und wir haben
jetzt die die anteil steigt jedes jahr
um ungefähr drei bis vier prozent das
heißt es absehbar dass es bald kaum
frauen gibt in der medizin das ist keine
gute entwicklung und die frage ist die
sterne die jetzt in der runde auf wenn
man sagt okay sie haben gesagt im
öffentlichen dienst und nicht ich
verstehe den unterschied ehrlich gesagt
nicht das müssen sie mir erklären
aber wollen wir jetzt in wenn es wenn es
berufe gibt die in ein in die andere
richtung gehen ist das auch eine sache
die man ansprechen sollte
ja ich habe
ganz kurz also zum beispiel so beim
start empfinde ich jetzt so der wirt vom
steuerzahler bezahlt die ämter da sollte
man die quoten einführen
privatwirtschaft nicht erzähle ich aber
gleich noch beim lastwagen weiter
schönen abend in not tut mir leid und
tschüss wir sehen uns morgen abend
wieder wenn sie mögen und 20 15
[Musik]